hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia a
machine for pigs okay so we need to find
a way to be able to open this portcullis
gate of some sort over here so what I'm
looking for is another way to throw a
switch now I don't know where this is
and I don't know how to get to it but
there appears to be something over here
haha okay I knew it had to be easy and I
knew it had to be in the area that I
just unlocked so let's see this fuse is
broken so I'm gonna need to go get it
okay me about whoa whoa whoa whoa the
[ __ ] was that oh [ __ ]
oh no oh no oh no did that sound like a
piggy to anybody else that maybe sound a
bit like a piggy piggy
I'm beginning haha once again I haven't
seen what the monsters look like so I
don't know what to expect
Vaughan Reichenbach writes of the old ik
force whilst the ignorant charlatan boov
Lasky pontificated upon the soul they're
both cretins to think one could strive
for such great heights without waiting
first we're puking in ered without
standing upon an architecture of bones
Montezuma was the wiser but here in our
temples of steel I have witnessed the
severed head of man recently trampled to
death by a runaway carriage immersed in
a solution of the brennenburg compound
open his eyes and cry oh where are my
leg sir where is my body we are breaking
through the barriers of death itself oh
my dead darling Lilly it is too late for
you but I promise you this I will save
our children from death and if need be I
will wrench them back from the blackness
with this wonderful concoction
so the Brandenburg concoction from
brennenburg castle I wonder why is my
lantern flickering
so the brennenburg concoction is
something obviously from brennenburg
castle something to do with what the
hell is that I start today
hi I saw something can't tell me I
didn't see something okay everybody go
back everybody go back about 15 seconds
look in the corner and the right there
am I just kidding myself I will tip
something there
everybody go back I'll forgive you
let's go back okay all right so things
are getting interesting I knew this is
set in the same universe as the previous
amnesia seems like someone I saw
something else gotta go back by that
flickering light over there know
something oh you cannot tell me that was
not something that time I know I know
there was something maybe I'm just being
paranoid
mm I'm just losing my mind maybe little
markiplier is going a little crazy
psycho bonkers crazy eh okay I got a
note get up there get up there
okay how did I get wait how what
intriguing the gates are far too heavy
for a man to lift instead voicing okay I
got I got ya okay
electrical sabotage I already got these
I just didn't see that I was getting
notes who this chemical process is
merely one of a Marshall object complex
I'll follow my fever the calls of my
children wherever they may leave me as I
move further through this - okay all
right all right everybody okay did I see
my ID oh oh those steamed down there
blah ha I got definitive proof that time
there was something there you sons of
[ __ ] you shut up you shut the Frick
frack up I don't want to hear anything
of it I don't hear want to cure god damn
word
seems like they have foregone oil and
tinderboxes for just the experience okay
no no what the hell happened here why
did I even need to do this if you're
just gonna blow everything up how do I
get up here
hand there's got to be a way right Oh
what happened
hope still but God's sake hold still
child don't let it get it your eyes I'm
gonna rinse it out now there it will be
fine you just need to lie down we don't
look to your brother how many times have
I told you not to play in the cellar
okay all right there we go I can
actually run now some and try make this
jump huh okay maybe I'm not supposed to
jump up there I have no idea
nevermind I'm not sure what that was all
about anyway okay so that portcullis has
now closed this one is open okay all
right
I told you he shut up kitty I know
you're dead I know you're dead
whatever you say bruh whatever you see
hello
what the hell
what
okay no on that one aha here we go
slang that one there we go yeah I'm
being sprayed with something that's
probably good that's good
ah here we go now I can turn this one
ah it was a decontamination protocol
interesting how do i how do I get out oh
here we go
okay so I've been thoroughly
decontaminated which means what exactly
I guess I can go into the lab now things
are getting whoa whoa don't look too
happy there lady all right definitely a
lot more variety the paintings in this
area hello mr. goat I just wonder when
the next Alexander painting is gonna
kill him along that was kind of effed up
okay so I'm actually thinking that this
game has completely abandoned all
pretense of a user interface in favor of
just having the experience be about
immersion here just immersion which is
great great fine with me don't even need
to deal with items or anything the
collar the neck the noose two cups of
flour one cup of water a pinch of salt
handful of mints bay leaf herbs skeleton
key for the nursery and the mixing will
go together oh man
nothing nothing beaten or on horror game
with great immersion
like I've known oh shut up you a-hole
I've noticed that it's gone more to
items interactable in the environment
the
okay I'm beginning to think that you are
actually the machine the machine for
pigs okay this occasionally I'll walk
into a room and get this chill go on my
spine because I know that something bad
will happen but then what if they could
stand upright and walk as men what if
the brood were honest thus would they
sing would they find their own God I've
seen these things and I will tell you no
they will not but they will happily
accept fealty to a God thrust upon them
and worship it thus given in this I
realized they are no different to the
masses they are much the same as us
wants to see a revocable threshold is
passed I understand that we too are
shackled and must be set free to free
the man we cut the man in order to cross
that great evolutionarily line and LU
evolutionary line it must first be
painted upon the ground so I think they
might be alluding it's like there's some
complicated language going on here this
is like eighth grade leaving reading
level [ __ ] here
yeah it's my favorite song here oh man
god my god my old jams in here in
America they talk of building their city
to the skies to me that seems folly but
perhaps it is a simple case of a nation
founded without a history of its own we
walk upon our histories they are
compacted into the very loan but in her
feet the engineers we employ talk to
this they talked of how when building
the underground trains they would often
come across older tunnels crisscrossing
the Capitol what palace is library
beneath us we are digging digging
excavating and reappropriation what we
find fit the center of the planet my
architect says tells me there is a great
iron ball at the center of the planet it
is the egg of the world true this is
very true at the center of them okay
that's weird all right oh that's
attractive good job yeah anyway there's
a great ball of iron that spins it's the
magnetic core that causes the magnetic
field that protects us from a lot of
cosmic rays and radiation and stuff we
integrate the very latest knowledge of
chemistry using low levels of laudanum
derivative in the feed to subdue the
product even before the initiation of
the process this means that when we drag
from from the holding pens on to the
line
they're less likely to panic and damage
machine components of the product or
themselves the section of the belt is
unsheathed in rubber kept well lit to
maintain good spirits and we have
actually found that the intelligent
placement of gramophones and simple
acoustic amplification tools tubes
around the line means we can use music
to further soothe the product we find
Busey particularly effective in this
regard if you say so
wait warning fueling pumps volatile
chemicals are in use these materials are
highly corrosive wear protection I
always do oh boy we've reached the pigs
hello Peggy Peggy
how you doing you ready to get fed into
machine mashed into mush okay no wait
there's a valve over there hello piggies
are you doing doing good good no wait
those note there see factory alottoni
that one it appears to be some kind of
fueling station automobiles demonstrated
the smells all wrong not petroleum see
machine must be significant in some way
okay is it blood is it pig blood is that
what I'm looking at so I need to find
something to fill I'm guessing I'm gonna
find it down here hello piggies how you
doing doing good good good to hear glad
you're doing okay wouldn't want you to
be uncomfortable before the slaughter
I'm outside again didn't I just go down
so confused
maybe I am outside or maybe I am
underground and it just looks like I'm
outside no I'm outside what the hell is
going on what the hell I'm so confused
where am I going let's climb this one
how about not haba no that is a cemetery
that's a cemetery Little Billy Edward
and Enoch Ethan and Herman heimer
okay
well two red dots that look like eyes
that's reassuring
ah what's this what do we got here
see see the canister looks like it may
fit the fuel pump I saw earlier okay
all right so I got to find me
well I got to get me back but my lights
flickering which may mean something bad
is gonna happen
Who am I kidding nothing but bad things
have been happening since I started this
so whatever you know what else I want to
know is why there is absolutely no one
around what is going on there seriously
is absolutely no one here which is not
uncommon for an amnesia game but it's
pretty uncommon for off being in the
real outside world at least brennenburg
was isolated I'm feeling whatever goop
this is into this container in the hopes
that it will lead me further okay I
didn't own it admit it oh that is a
biggie biggie what's on the leg oh okay
just fill it the rest of the way it's
coming did you get on it
piggy baby's coming Oh gonna get a good
evening oh my god get it
Oh Big E big is coming get me get me get
what am i doing with this I don't even
know I know I know oh I can put it in
able to didn't even see him okay that I
watch him I don't want you I don't I
never seen come on Logan
what do I deal with this what do I doing
this bluie dude dude no no I can tell
you honey nobody doing with my life okay
I don't even know oh okay look
oh my gudd oh my gudd hi I'm okay what
do i do what do I do with this I have no
idea I don't even know what I'm doing
right now this is a door I can't go in
there this is a bunch of lights I know
there's a piggy piggy back there I don't
know if he's gone I don't even know if
he was coming after me I don't think it
matters maybe he put in hi here we go oh
man oh all right
um it's just replacing the tank okay
blue hi
how long were you there I'm willing to
bet not the whole time
oh Christ what am I doing with my life
what am i doing am I supposed to be
driving this son of a [ __ ]
I put the fuel thing in there so what do
I do oh okay well that's something I got
to move this out of the way somehow come
on get in gear how do I get you go oh I
see
it's one oh I remember cuz old vehicles
used to always be like this
ah that's all I needed just to move a
slight burst don't know a little anybody
but I can I'm too wimpy I can't push
that what am i talking
hello whatever this way papa come and
see one hatch help me take it home yes
my god of course we can take it no how
about no your stone egg is that what
you're talking about
what what what the hell is that what is
that oh my god what is that that looks
like the grunt from amnesia but
different is that the monster I'm
running away from holy crap what is
going on what's going on we go down
oh don't have with me buddy don't have
with me I'm not in the mood I'm not in
the mood to be effed with
so let's just carry on through the
cemetery I saw something blowing in the
wind here this can I go in here
apparently not okay
ah good down into the chapel good good
good good good good
okay livestock and Bibles Lily dancing
Lily dancing on the table her eyes a
flame this love burnt into his heart his
scar hearts scarred from the heat of
this love of his love dancing lots of
love lots of dancing live shocking
Bibles all right so let's read this note
see we sat here I remember we sat in our
black and we mourned and we prayed and
we bowed our heads how I hated God then
how I spurned him if this is our Lord
this pig who robs me of my wife then I
refute his embrace I will carve a new
god for us all such madness such a fool
I was if such blasphemous ravings had
remained within me I would be doomed but
even here I feel the Machine throb
beneath the flags and I know my path
awaits me what kind of machine did this
guy build I am so into this I'm so into
this
so anyway oh man I barely saw that much
of the monster I flipped my [ __ ] who is
amazing this game it's gonna be
incredible so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
that's new music